[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle édition de parlement hebdo le
meilleur de la semaine politique et
parlementaire avec à mes côtés kathia
gilder bonjour ktm bonjour aurait amené
cette semaine nous recevons david
assouline
bonjour bonjour à vous retrouver vous
êtes sénateur socialiste de paris vice
président du sénat et on va donc
déroulée la semaine avec vous la fin des
consultations sur la révision
constitutionnelle
pas d'avancée chacun campe sur ses
positions l'exécutif dévoilera les
propositions retenues dans les prochains
jours
la réforme de la sncf et du statut des
cheminots se fera par voie d'ordonnancé
le projet de loi qui autorise l'exécutif
à prendre des mesures a été présentée
une grève de longue durée s'annonce et
puis la simplification administrative
était à l'ordre du jour du sénat
le texte instaure un droit à l'erreur
pour le citoyen et on commence par le
feuilleton de la révision
constitutionnelle
cette semaine fin des consultations
parlementaires à matignon
[Musique]
ces deux derniers entretiens mercredi
edouard philippe les a réservé à
françois de rugy le président de
l'assemblée nationale et gérard larcher
le président du sénat
c'est lui l'homme à convaincre pour
cette révision constitutionnelle mais
même si edouard philippe s'est bien
gardé de livrer les détails de sa
réforme il ne semble pas avoir infléchi
ses positions quand un calme et mercredi
à matignon c'est lui qu'il s'agissait de
convaincre
une mission compliquée car depuis des
mois sur plusieurs sujets gérard larcher
a placé des lignes rouges
le président du sénat s'oppose à
l'interdiction du cumul des mandats dans
le temps mais également à un statut de
la corse mentionné dans un article à
part et insiste pour conserver une bonne
représentativité des territoires
de l'autre côté de la table peu
d'informations sur ce que l'exécutif
entend véritablement faire depuis
plusieurs jours le premier ministre
présente les grandes lignes de sa
réforme constitutionnelle mais sans
jamais véritablement entrer dans les
détails
parmi les pistes avancées une dose de
proportionnelle aux législatives
ou encore la réduction du nombre de
parlementaires autant de mesures qui
déséquilibrent nos institutions
selon les présidents de groupe lr le
premier risque à éviter ces d'affaiblir
un peu plus le parlement le parlement
sous la vème république est très
affaibli hélas les propositions nous
propose c'est d'affaiblir encore plus le
parlement pour donner une forme de toute
puissance au chef de l'état
mais ces mesures sont populaires d'après
les derniers sondages publiés
ainsi l'exécutif pourrait être tenté par
la voie du référendum si les discussions
avec son opposition parlementaire venait
a totalement échoué
david assouline chacun campe sur ses
positions en voix mais ce que vous
pensez que la voie parlementaire peut
encore aboutir j'espère que on va se
rassembler sur une volonté qui est celle
de renforcer la démocratie parlementaire
elle est faible dans la vème république
on voit bien que la tendance dans le
monde
c'est à considérer que la démocratie
affaibli l'efficacité donc on va vers
des régimes autoritaires j'ai entendu
des propos nique
sarkozy d'ailleurs très bizarre dans une
conférence ou leurs vues il loue et ses
régimes comme celui de monsieur poutine
donc je crois qu'aujourd'hui avec une
valve populiste qui existent en france
on la connaît il faut au contraire
revaloriser le rôle du parlement montrer
que la démocratie est synonyme
d'efficacité et inversement il n'ya pas
d'efficacité sans démocratie et donc là
je vois une réforme qui ne cherchent pas
dans ce qui est annoncé à renforcer
l'efficacité du travail de ce moment
c'est en tout cas parce que l'exécutif
l'exécutif n'a pas de dévoiler oui mais
on voit bien ce qui est avancé c'est il
faut faire plus efficacement la loi mais
moi je constate comme parlementaire que
très souvent la loi est mal faite parce
que l'exécutif qu'à lille la
quasi-totalité de l'initiative
parlementaire
nous vous nous donne les lois qui vous
sans étude d'impact réel
il n'y a pas le suivi derrière et c'est
souvent l'exécutif qui la ficelle man et
nous consacrons nous au sénat en
particulier nous sommes attachés à un
travail de fond
très souvent c'est nous qui corrige les
imperfections de la loi donc par exemple
le droit d'amendement qui est menacée on
en parle pour chaque pour chaque
parlementaire
je vais vous dire on peut s'opposer
surtout quand on est l opposition mais
la réalité c'est que quand on fait un
amendement me propose
on va y revenir sur ce droit
d'amendement oui on va écouter andré
chassaigne mais sur une des lignes
rouges déjà un marché par exemple le non
cumul des mandats dont le temps
l'exécutif veut limiter ce cumul des
mandats 3 est ce que ça c'est un point
de blocage pour vous aussi au pas du
tout non c'est pas ça le point de
blocage de d'autant que le parti
socialiste a fait cette proposition ait
fait cette proposition dans depuis un
certain temps trois bombes à ça va c'est
bien vous n'êtes pas contre on n'est pas
contre en est même pour avant même que c
était proposée par ou en marche ou par
le président
y compris pour les cellules mais la
championne l'exécutif à exclure les
mêmes demain 3508 oui oui c'est bien
aussi mais je sais c'est pas là le sujet
le sujet de fondamental c est ce que
l'on renforce le parlement où est ce que
l'on renforce le pouvoir de l'exécutif
or aujourd'hui il y a y compris dans la
méthode moi j'aime regarder ce qui est
fait concrètement ordonnance sur le code
du travail
ordonnance sur la loi ferroviaire vote
bloqué sur les retraites des
agriculteurs
la tendance de ce pouvoir de ce
gouvernement et de vendeurs et de l à
l'autoritarisme et au pouvoir bâtir mais
est ce que cette révision
constitutionnel renforce les pouvoirs du
parlement comme vous le demander où est
ce qu'à nourrir l'antiparlementarisme
pour moi elle nourrit dont il
parlementarisme c'est ce que je disais
tout à l'heure le sait alimenter le fait
que le parlement est là pour bavarder
alors qu'il faut être efficace c'est
réduire le nombre de parlementaires par
exemple bien entendu ce lundi aux
français ils sont trop bon c'est vrai
que ils vivent une efficacité de
l'action publions qui se disent ils sont
trop pour peu de résultats mais la
réalité c'est que si on pose la question
aux français ce que vous voulez des
parlementaires alors j'y suis éloigné de
vous si en à moi ils seront plus
éloignés dans le territoire de chaque
citoyen ça sera des circonscriptions
plus large lui c'est donc ce que je
pense je finis là dessus c'est que il
faut arrêter de d'aller dans le sens du
populisme parce que ceux qui gouvernent
vont recevoir le retour de bâton très
fort parce que l'on sait que c'est pas
seulement en france mais dans toute
l'europe
c'est une tendance qu'il faut combattre
alors vous en parlais à l'instant le
gouvernement aurait aussi l'intention de
limiter le droit d'amendement des
parlementaires en fonction de
l'importance des groupes politiques
écouter le coup de gueule d'andré
chassaigne lors des questions
d'actualité à l'assemblée
monsieur le premier ministre les
dernières initiatives du gouvernement
sont marqués du sceau du mépris à
l'égard de leur représentation nationale
et donc de la démocratie
ces coups de force répéter monsieur le
premier ministre marque une dangereuse
dérive aux accents de dictature
technocratique
il donne le temps de la réforme des
institutions à venir avec en particulier
la restriction du droit d'amendement des
parlementaires
il ne s'agit pas simplement de
rationaliser ou de rafraîchir le
fonctionnement du parlement
c'est l'avenir même de notre démocratie
qui est en jeu en matière de rapports
entre l'exécutif et le législatif
ma doctrine est simple rien que la
constitution mais toute la constitution
est-ce que vous pensez que le
gouvernement va vraiment sortir de son
chapeau cette proposition abbas et
blanches des shows droit c'est lui qui
en parle alors où ils manoeuvrent nation
il agite en tous les cas nous le vivons
comme une provocation mais je pense que
que que si le défendent les ponts
sérieux s'ils le mettent sur la table
c'est qu'ils veulent faire ça ils
veulent tester ça ce n'est pas possible
moi ma principale fierté comme
parlementaire depuis que je le suis
j'ai été plus souvent dans l'opposition
que dans la majorité c'est on peut se
sentir inutile
est ce que le notre rôle est de dire non
non non non bah si on n'a pas le droit
d'amendement ont dit non c'est du procès
ces protestataires or c'est dans
l'amendement qu'on est obligé de
proposer autre chose conformisme le
confort mule de la proposition est donc
ce droit individuel est très important
et ma fierté c'est même quand dans la
constitution française
j'avais réussi en 2008 à faire passer un
amendement sur l'indépendance le
pluralisme et la liberté des médias
alors que j'étais dans l'opposition
c'est dans la constitution je me dis
j'ai été utile même comme opposants
cette semaine david assouline le
gouvernement a donné le top départ de la
réforme de la sncf le projet de loi
était présenté en conseil des ministres
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
transformation de la sncf en société
anonyme fin du statut de cheminot pour
les nouveaux embauchés tels sont les
deux mesures phares du projet de loi qui
autorise le gouvernement à réformer
l'entreprise par ordonnance un contenu
autant qu'une méthode qui suscite moult
aux critiques
stéphanie des pierres des ordonnances
pour aller plus vite c'est l'argument du
gouvernement pour justifier le recours à
ce procédé est en même temps ils
essaient de montrer qu'il reste ouvert
au dialogue
elisabeth bornes la ministre des
transports le martèle le projet de loi
indique le cadre de la réforme mais les
discussions ne sont pas terminées et le
texte pourra évoluer au fil de la
concertation dès qu'un sujet aura
suffisamment avancé il sera introduit
par amont par amendement dans le débat
parlementaire à la place des ordonnances
moi je le dis clairement cette méthode
est celle qui donne le plus de place à
la concertation pour l'instant cette
méthode ne convainc ni les syndicats ni
l'opposition qui dénonce l'utilisation
des ordonnances et un gouvernement qui
choisit l'affrontement sur le fond de la
réforme
elisabeth borne à confirmer la fin du
statut des cheminots pour les nouvelles
recrues
c'est une ligne rouge pour les syndicats
sur quatre pages le projet de loi
organise aussi l'ouverture à la
concurrence du réseau sncf
en revanche le gouvernement ne touchera
pas aux petites lignes non rentables
edouard philippe l'avait dit elisabeth
bornes l'a confirmé le gouvernement a
dit très clairement et j'ai pas de doute
sur le fait que la sncf suis des
orientations du gouvernement que nous ne
suivrons pas le rapport spinetta sur ce
sujet ce sont des lignes qui méritent
d'être examinées au cas par cas qui
recouvrent des réalités différentes sur
lequel l'état a pris des engagements
dans le cadre des contrats de plan état
région et ses engagements seront tenus
le débat sur la réforme du rail
devraient commencer mi avril à
l'assemblée
le recours aux ordonnances à la bonne
méthode david assouline pour faire
installer un temps difficiles le lien
avec la discussion de tout à l'heure
et très souvent on dit que la forme
c'est le fond et la forme des
ordonnances sur eux bien sûr qu'il ya
des sujets où on a souvent attendues
pour réformer mais maintenant si ce
gouvernement veut réformer
il doit savoir que sur des sujets
essentiels qui est matrix le contrat
social qui existant depuis des décennies
donc c'était le code du travail là c'est
la sncf qui est au delà de la sncf
symbolique le rapport spinetta s'étaient
annoncés un an de travail ensuite on a
dit six mois finalement ces trois mois
donc le rapport lui-même son élaboration
ensuite il est mis sur la table on nous
dit ça va pas être la loi normale on
discute on amende et le temps de la
concertation avec les syndicats on nous
dit c'est pas ordonnance et les
syndicats ce n'est pas content aussi
parce qu'il n'ya pas cette concertation
donc moi j'ai entendu là je me suis
immergé alors a dit martinez comment il
a choisi l'affrontement les premiers
ministres comme le passage en force mais
ccc c'est une méthode c'est une méthode
très personnelle de gouvernement très
très brutale de gouvernement et je ne
crois pas qu'on réforme notre pays de
cette façon la détermination ce n'est
pas la brutalité et je veux dire j'ai
entendu le responsable à cdt qui n'est
pas considéré comme un irresponsable
dire rappelé il y a eu l'année dernière
70 mille cheminots étaient entre 1 et 1
3 du smig et on va nous dire c'est ça
les nouveaux riches par contre oui oui
voyez je pense que c'est la place de
tous ceux qui veulent défendre non
seulement les droits des travailleurs
mais aussi un système ferroviaire qui
fonctionne pas suffisamment bien et
probablement il ya des problèmes
d'organisation il faut mettre ça sur la
table mais ce n'est pas le niveau de
rémunération les avantages pour les
cheminots qui sont la faute de cela je
crois que vraiment désigné aux français
des cheminots comme les privilégiés
alors que nous sommes passés à deux de
dividendes et d'une augmentation du
nombre de milliardaires dans ce pays de
façon gigantesque ce ne sont pas eux les
nouveaux riches au contraire et donc je
pense qu'il faut arrêter ce populisme ça
encore c'est du populisme et c'est
monter les français les uns contre les
autres des pauvres contre des pauvres
autre sujet david assouline cette
semaine le sénat examiner le projet de
loi de simplification administrative
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le texte a déjà été voté par les députés
son objectif redonner confiance dans
l'administration sa mesure phare
l'instauration d'un droit à l'erreur
mais au fur et à mesure de son examen le
texte a perdu de sa cohérence est en
tout cas ce qu'ont dénoncé une partie
des sénateurs quand un calme et
accrochez vous les thèmes concernés par
ce projet de loi droit à l'erreur était
pour le moins divers à la limite de la
confusion à l'origine le texte visait à
créer une indulgence pour les
utilisateurs des services publics
principalement prévu pour
l'administration fiscale
le sénat avait dès l'examen en
commission étendu ce droit à l'erreur
aux collectivités territoriales et à la
sécu finalement en séance c'est aussi le
droit à l'environnement et même les
démarches européennes comme la pac qui
ont été ajoutées beaucoup plus difficile
ensuite de trouver une cohérence à la
suite de l'examen de ce texte sur les
bancs dlr comme du parti socialiste ont
dénoncé cet aspect fourre-tout
sincèrement mais où est ce qu'on est
c'est le senate la république et le
sénat de la république en est à débattre
de savoir s'ils ont montré un numéro de
téléphone et j ce numéro de téléphone
doit être ou pas à habiliter être joint
pas jointes ou et la prochaine fois
faites vous faire les circulaires
exemple avec les parcs éoliens à la
dernière minute le gouvernement entend
renégocier les tarifs de rachat de
l'électricité produite en mer levée de
boucliers immédiate des sénateurs
bretons et normands séné renégociation
ne peuvent se faire sous la contrainte
avec effet rétroactif comme le proposent
l'amendement du gouvernement qui crée un
véritable risque pour la filière de
l'éolien maritime
autre sujet les lieux de culte la
haute-assemblée adopte un amendement sur
la traçabilité des flux financiers dans
leur construction
aujourd'hui quand se construire un lieu
de culte et disons les choses clairement
une mosquée dans une commune on ne sait
pas qui la finance
on ne sait pas qui est derrière ce
projet avec ce texte le gouvernement
permet également aux représentants des
cultes de ne plus être considérés comme
des lobbys et ce malgré les
protestations venues de la gauche qui
peut contester
que les associations cultuelles entre
dans le champ de la définition légale
des représentants d'intérêts les lois
sur le mariage pour tous ou en faveur
des malades et des personnes en fin de
vie peuvent témoigner que les
associations cultuelles pèse dans le
débat public
reste désormais à adopter l'ensemble de
ce texte
le vote solennel est prévu au palais du
luxembourg mardi prochain david
assouline pour vous aussi ce texte
manquer de cohérence
ah oui c'est le moins qu'on puisse dire
65 article il part des bons ils
partaient de quelque chose de tout à
fait louable qui est une simplification
et le fait qu' on est le droit à
l'erreur dont les rapports avec
l'administration et que ce soit
l'administration qui doit prouver qu'il
ya eu mauvaise volonté et c'est bon tout
cela est ressenti par les français par
nous tous et c'est bien mais après voilà
un texte fourre tout où on aborde à la
va vite des sujets qui mériterait d'être
approfondie
et puis d'autres où on met au parlement
en discussion franchement des sujets
qu'on pourrait régler par simplification
par circulaire par décret car ici tout à
l'heure qui de façon humoristique disait
notre sentiment
et puis quand on a des lois ballet de ce
type est bien chacun il vient il en
rajouter et mettre du sien puis là on
voit des choses importantes la loi de
1905 sur la laïcité qui est remise en
question à travers un article on sort du
champ des lobbys les organisations
cultuelles et on a bien vu ce troll à
dire ah oui là c'est un problème parce
que on n'arrête pas de polémique et de
discuter sur la laïcité de façon
violente sans s'enfonçant qu'on puisse
maîtriser des choses être responsable
dans ce débat et d'un coup quand ça
arrive au parlement c'est par la petite
bande n'y a pas de débat et on touche à
des principes fondamentaux donc vraiment
c'est pas sérieux
et justement c'est l'exemple même cdh
exécutif qui devrait faire attention à
comment ils fabriquent la loi y propose
la loi ce ne sont pas les parlementaires
qui la font mal et comme
ancien président de la commission de
contrôle d'application des lois j'ai
beaucoup fait attention à la façon dont
on fabrique la loi dont elle est évaluée
j'attache de l'importance mais c'est en
revalorisant le parlement qu'on y
arrivera et justement ce texte va
revenir à l'assemblée entre il y aura
une cmp une commission mixte paritaire
pour essayer de trouver une version
commune entre les deux sens vous pensez
que ça va aboutir ou pas l'assemblée
ayant le dernier mot
je ne sais pas parce que très
franchement même socialiste qui sommes
une opposition gauche au gouvernement
je nous ne sommes pas contre le principe
essentiel qui est niché dans un article
de l'article 2 voilà donc il y a des
choses importantes
il faudra commencer jeu où on va
discuter est exactement de notre
position mais très franchement je
souhaite bout du du courage à ceux qui
vont être à la cmp
parce que quand il ya autant d'armes
édition pour se mettent d'accord c'est
compliqué on va passer à la partie
politique de cette émission david
assouline avec notre partenaire du
figaro.fr
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et en accueille jim jara s'est vengé sur
quatre bonjour david assouline bonjour
vous êtes un soutien d'olivier fort est
arrivé en tête au premier tour si on
peut appeler ça comme ça du du congrès
du parti socialiste stéphane le foll qui
était le second annoncé qu'il jetait
l'épongé
l'hiver fort sera donc selon toute
logique le prochain patron du ps est ce
que c'est une bonne nouvelle pour vous
oui bien sûr c'est une bonne nouvelle il
ya plusieurs bonnes nouvelles la bonne
nouvelle d'abord c'est que ceux qui
disaient le ps est mort moi quand
quarantaine de milliers de militants
viennent physiquement peu de partis font
ça hein
maintenant on fait des clics on adhère
comme ça c'est aux cotisations la fois à
jour de cotisations elles sont sérieuses
ou paris social et plus de20 congrès de
reims c'est une évidence que nous avons
en ce minerai 7 qui va nier ici en tous
les cas pas moi le fait que nous sommes
sortis très affaibli
très malade à tel point que il faut une
renaissance n'est pas seulement une
reconstruction il ya mais il y a
quarante mille militants des milliers
d'élus qui sont là qui existe qui
viennent physiquement voter s'intéresser
à un débat politique
donc c'est pas mort c'est même l'un
vertes pour moi c'est le bourgeon d'un
printemps de la renaissance socialiste
qui s'annonce et est en plus deuxième
bonne nouvelle
olivier forges pense était celui qui
rassemblait vous savez ceux qui sont
restés socialiste justement sont peu
nombreux dans le pays
donc ce succès déjà presque un grand
courant par rapport à la société
reconnue donc big donc s'amuser à se
mobiliser car justement alors déjà
rassembler le parti vous l'avait dit et
puis élargir sa base de légitimité on
assure d'abord en faisant travailler
ensemble socialistes parce que les
quatre candidats peuvent travailler
ensemble et
vous savez il faut d'abord reconstruire
un collectif notre dette a été un peu
décapité donc ça c'est du travail
les rennais rejet des nouvelles têtes et
on peut pas sans arrêt demandé le
renouvellement en disant il n'est pas
assez connu enfin bon c'est si on veut
du renouvellement c'est des nouvelles
têtes dont olivier faure n'est pas né de
la dernière pluie il a une expérience
mais surtout c'est sa volonté est de
rassembler et sa capacité que j'ai senti
déjà à rassembler des gens assez
différents et des territoires en partant
de la base que que que j'ai soutenu je
suis très content qu'ils étaient ce
score en plus dans ma propre section
aussi ou un fait près de 60%
donc à tous les niveaux ce matin je suis
satisfait parce que on pouvait avoir
peur d'un congrès qui se passent mal
avec notre participation avec beaucoup
de révisions et bien c'est une très
bonne nouvelle il ya un sondage qui
était dur pour le ps cette semaine 62%
des français qui ont une mauvaise image
du ps c'est à égalité avec le front
national le pire la pire image pour un
parti politique au sein de l'opinion
publique s'il y avait une chose à faire
une chose pour redorer l'image du ps
selon vous david assouline qu'est ce que
ce serait c'est travail et reconstruire
cette confiance papa faire le bilan de
notre exercice du pouvoir parce que pour
nous refaire confiance il faudra qu'on
dise qu'on va changer dans la méthode
c'est être humble et puis travailler à
faire des nouvelles propositions et pas
seulement des nouvelles propositions
face à celle du pouvoir en place mais à
penser un projet de société sur les
questions essentielles des grandes
mutations sur lesquels il ya peu de de
vraies perspectives solides sur la
révolution écologique il faut faire le
fait que pour nous le social maintenant
doit être complètement liés à l'écologie
et qu'il n'ya pas d'écologie son social
il n'y a pas de socialisme et écologie
mais il ya aussi sur les grands défis
démographiques sur la révolution
technologique
il ya une révolution du travail et donc
il faut repenser les outils de la
de la solidarité sociale qui s'est
construite à partir d'une autre
organisation du travail là dessus il
faut avancer et travailler on a aperçu
françois hollande qui est venu voter
seul ferino jeudi soir il va sortir un
livre qui est assez attendu et ce qu'il
a encore sa voix au chapitre le l'ex
président la république au sein du moros
et c'est l'ancien président de la
république et sa voix au chapitre sur
cette sottise non mais ça ça veut dire
quoi
la voix au chapitre est ce que ea la
politique au sein du parti je dépense
que sa parole que les deux arrivés en
tête soit olivier faure et stéphane le
foll c'est un peu la victoire de
françois hollande
je pense que si c'était stéphane le foll
ça aurait signifié l'incarnation malgré
ce qu'il peut dire de on a tout bien
fait et puis voilà or olivier faure
n'est pas là dessus moi j'ai aussi
soutenir la ligne g j'ai soutenu olivier
faur aussi parce que j'ai vu parce que
j'en étais au moment de débats
fondamentaux sur la réforme de la
nationalité mais aussi sur la loi elle
conneries
nous avons mené des bagarres dans les
instances à l'intérieur en toute loyauté
nous les avons perdus et olivier faure
était au rendez vous pour essayer de
changer les choses
donc pas béni oui oui et je pense que
c'est ce qui lui donne une autorité et
et je pense qu'on va se reconstruire ce
sera comme ça et en se rassemblant c'est
donc le mot de la fin david assouline
merci merci merci merci merci à vous on
se retrouve dans la semaine prochaine
avant de se quitter
je voudrais bien un petit moment ma
partenaire kathia gilder qui va
s'absenter quelques semaines pour un
heureux événement vous allez nous
manquer car ça on vous souhaite plein de
belles choses et puis on retrouve avec
plaisir dans quelques semaines avec les
eu vraiment de suite de programmes très
bientôt ciao
[Musique]